hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is Sean Evans checking in in between
season five and season six did not want
to leave you empty-handed on a Thursday
without those spicy chicken wings that
you crave so much and people have been
asking me where's Machine Gun Kelly
around two people in between me what
happened to the second Machine Gun Kelly
interview well if you followed us on
Super Bowl Sunday
you saw Machine Gun Kelly take on the
wings of death for a second time and a
very special musical performance
unfortunately the performance was only a
Super Bowl Sunday event but we did want
to bring back the interview dust it off
it's a hot ones lost tape Machine Gun
Kelly round two sands and musical
performance
don't complain that there's not a
musical performance because I'm telling
you right now there's not gonna be a
musical performance but without further
ado Machine Gun Kelly round two fight
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even had her wings and
it's a banner day a hot ones first
we have returning to this seat Machine
Gun Kelly yeah he's been a busy guy
since last we eight releasing his third
studio album bloom touring the world in
his new single home is everywhere MGK
how does it feel to be back feel spicy
well you know spicy right now we have
completely different sauces this time
around the good news is you're doing
half as many wings the bad news is some
of these are considerably hotter than
last time you know the first hot wing I
ever ate it was with me yeah I feel
special you ready to do it again I am
alright so this first one is the hot one
sauce we're out here I'm gonna take my
stand-up mark those are meant for like
sucking blood that's a blues guys the
whole week okay I'm coming out to the
boneless huh but we we dance around it
last time let's get to it so I actually
want to start by taking it back to that
fateful day two and a half years ago
you're one of our first guests into this
day still a fan favorite and I'm
wondering what was the reaction like
afterwards have you run into
hot ones fans in the while absolutely
dude some people got hip to me through
that damn as hot but they discovered me
by eating some [ __ ] chicken wings so
it is a trip you know man and then the
top comment on your YouTube video as I
thought MGK was gonna fight him holy
[ __ ] what if anything do you remember
about the experience how close were you
to break him um you want my honest
answer I want to be in a building that
that day really honest yeah I had I had
I had I had some other things I was
upset about so you were just 100% gonna
get it you know me and your last
question maybe want to just punch you in
the face MGK are you in love oh but you
have a punchable face people have said
that lesson Oh what was the aftermath
like how bad did we [ __ ] up your day it
was the absolute like where should have
taken in my entire life and I had a
whole string of interviews that day
that's do you don't man yeah there's
nothing worse than being a poet places
trying to like just keep it together and
yeah having those hot ones cold sweats
yeah damn that's that's really hot the
Karma sauce extreme Karma it's like I
have a lot of that comment anyway you
know it means I don't know if I'm
excited about this that this one right
here that's this wing right here let's
clean it so for many Machine Gun Kelly
is a stage-diving speaker climbing rage
animal but the real ones know that
there's a softer side to gonna what do
you like at the parent-teacher
conferences oh dude I went in to read at
my at my daughter's school the other day
bunch of little eight-year-old some of
them were like mad tough to you know
early in their in their life what's this
dude about you know what a minute like
oh this your dad oh look at him man
what's up with what's this dude's deal I
had to read his book and it was just I
started reading and I was like oh my god
it's a funny book like it's supposed to
be funny you know I mean I started
saying some punchlines and they weren't
they weren't hidden it was not played
was not and I was like tough crowd and I
looked up and I seen I see my kid
you know like and then that one plus
like a where I said and the booger
dripped down
Katie's faces when the whole class like
ah ha ha start dying laughing it was at
that point that I knew I want him over I
walked out of that classroom like a
goddamn rock star that they all were
like best book reader guest yet this one
is the bomb which is maybe the toughest
one in the entire lineup this it don't
[Music]
you know remember that uh that clean the
chicken with whole [ __ ] you know
immediately that [ __ ] was a dumb idea on
my part why are you laughing are you
laughing like that
well [ __ ] is everyone looking like that
mooning painful you why did you do this
to me dude what is that what is this
listen I feel like you did this to me
too
you know this whole cleaning the wings
situation just like last time taking
some laps you really kind of invented
the hot ones laugh
[Applause]
so I know that there's a softer side to
Machine Gun Kelly but the real ones know
that you can also be a speaker climbing
stage-diving rage animal it's on this
wing I want to focus on your world tour
get some stories from the road did you
get in trouble out there I saw some
tweets somebody couldn't eat this [ __ ]
right now cuz I know you're thinking I'm
[ __ ] playing dippers Saint come here
handsome de Bono chicken wings we're
gonna need one chicken wing cuz this is
no one's I'm not not too happy but
looking to me crazy someone feel is wait
what was that question did you get in
trouble on your world tour
well our bus got searched four times I
ended up into jail cells one in Norway
one and [ __ ] and family and your son
careful around your eyes and and I just
got detained at the hello X Airport for
something that will probably never ever
say until the statue limitations over
y'all got zoom on here there's one
lonely tear this movie [ __ ] except movie
[ __ ] comes from the center of the guys
when you know it's fake this this right
here in the corner that's a real tear
don't mean this breath all right are you
still on the hole clean the wing thing
or you kind of want to do a bite where
are you at with that I am unfortunately
a man of my word so now we got to just
do it
would you stop starting just help me out
okay listen to this I got that one
trying to catch up with that let us but
there's nowhere to go you know it's just
both of us okay so at least give me like
a 1 2 3 so I just I don't want to
participate 1 2 3
[Music]
okay I can't face I can't even taste so
let's take it to a happier place because
you recently played a sold-out hometown
concert in Cleveland I know the tu-16 it
holds a very special place in your heart
what's more Cleveland polish boys or
pierogies pros boys honestly like we do
you like corned beef
you know I'm something like gosh llamas
grab a really good corned beef pastrami
sandwich
that's what Cleveland best rapper to
come out of Cleveland not yourself go
listen to the [ __ ] off from Cleveland
to mixtape it was a lot of people that
really just like inspired me in my whole
career that I'm still friends with all
those guys you know I'm saying on that
tape and they they they really kind of
paved the way from you so that's a good
tape damn bigger source of Cleveland
pride Superman or Drew Carey got
Superman was there I mean Jimmy Drew
Carey be partying crazy together I'm a
girly somebody I didn't party with
Superman yeah he didn't come he didn't
he didn't tap in for me
so I drew Carey you create that man you
know it's crazy yeah yeah I mean jus
Carey's gonna [ __ ] with me since back
when I was I would do a cover of what's
my age again my big money too and I
would take all my clothes off this be
right before a wild boy so Drew Carey
was rockin with me since back in those
days like he would show up to the show
with like five hot blond girls you know
and he would show up random he would
even like announce himself up tonight
he'd just be sitting there chilling he'd
be like looking at like we see like I
take a sea of these beautiful and he's
like damn like what's that dolphin he
doing and then there's Drew Carey with
like eight bottles in the middle of them
like Cleveland you know dude
I mean it just carried on tradition do
it like any concert on that like you can
just pop oh you know you just walk
backstage after show there's drew Carey
respect Cleveland oh dude
broke my foot broke my [ __ ] ankle in
four places guess who sent me flowers
drew Carey drew Carey dude what a sweet
I woke up there's like a thing of like
it's like orchids or something that's
like metaphoric towards like he'll you
know I mean whatever the [ __ ] so he
thought about it and I look and I'm like
you know I know and it's like you know
clean the love get get your leg better
so you can you know go rock it drew
Carey
all right Machine Gun Kelly ever feeling
drew Carey might have to send more
flowers after this interview this is the
last dab we call it the last dab because
it's tradition around here
to put a little extra on the last wing
but you want to know something special
Machine Gun Kelly yeah I wanna know do
you know who invented dabbing the last
wing a tradition that has carried on for
now almost a hundred episodes and into
our fifth season who do you know who
originated it who you me you you are the
one that we're like let's put a little
extra I'm the last wing and that's a
tradition that has now carried on into
the fifth season of the show amazing
that is the story of my life did doing
things that I do not remember doing all
right cheers my man was it good to be
back do you want the honest answer do
you want the camera verge on you know I
[ __ ] love you Dino I Love You Man
thank you wonder [ __ ] a successful year
you too for real
thank you for having me on the show
earlier on I believe in to me if this
wing is too spicy I will punch you in
the face
okay not bad touch like an island II
mm-hmm you know that Island breeze damn
dog mm-hmm where do Island breeze go
yeah that's the thing is it kind of
comes in nicely but then it has a little
bit of a tail I don't like a girlfriend
it just comes in really nice right all
right and then eventually at the point
when you think it's all going good the
roller coaster goes the other direction
all right Machine Gun Kelly typically
I'm the last wing we have our guests do
some sort of challenge maybe say
something inspirational try to answer
one more question without passing out on
set but with you we have the toughest
wing ten challenge of them all where's
the microphone who has that microphone
Oh God
you've been known to be a nonconformist
someone who breaks down barriers I don't
think anyone has ever done a live show
with three million scovilles coursing
through them but now you have no choice
because the sound is checked the band is
ready and the people are out there it's
time to go kill it my man
fangs in glasses on Clark becomes
Superman
MGK taking the stage hot ones
two times cut it
one dab to dab three dab what the what
this is Sean Evans checking in from a
wingless table and you know what that
means we're proud to announce a new
member of the last dab family
Trinidad's famous Moruga scorpion pepper
the hottest pepper in the world from
2012 to 2013 is now in the fold same
base recipe and no one loved but now
with a new super hot in the mix and I
know that one of you spice Lords out
there is going to hit the triple dab the
scorpion into the Reaper into the pepper
ax you know the drill heat nice calm by
it while supplies last
Godspeed spice Lords be careful out
there